[Musique]
et j'accueille à présent mélanie poquet
bonsoir votre rendez vous aux loisirs
vous allez faire parler notre âme
d'enfants de 7 à 77 ans ce week-end les
lego envahissent le perray-en-yvelines
des petites briques par milliers dans
les 600 m² de la salle de la main rôle
ou du perray-en-yvelines quarantaine
d'exposants va partager sa passion pour
ce jeu qui a rythmé l'enfance de
beaucoup d'entre nous c'est
l'association breezy qu'ils organisent
plusieurs diorama vont être présentés ça
représente en général un mois de travail
et cette exposition va vous faire
voyager à travers différents divers
univers où on décide de mettre en avant
une un petit m
pour pour faire quelque chose d'un peu
plus grand que les autres cette année on
a décidé de mettre en avant le train on
a prévu un circuit d'à peu près 25
mètres de long où on va faire circuler
des trains si possible dans les autres
dans les dioramas deux exposants mais il
y en aura aussi pour tous les goûts
mélanie certains exposants vont
s'inspirer des univers fantastiques star
wars ça ça me plait harry potter et et
aussi les super héros et ils vont pas
oublier bien sûr la ville légaux sur ces
deux jours d'exposition il y aura aussi
plein d'animations le public pourra
notamment piloté des créations sur un
bassin nautique on pourra construire une
mosaïque on pourra même créé son propre
dieu rama
alors pour vivre 100% légaux rendez vous
samedi 19 et dimanche 20 octobre ou
perray en yvelines
le samedi c'est de 9h à 19h le dimanche
de 9 heures à 17 heures comptez 2 euros
pour les plus de 16 ans merci mélanie on
vous retrouve dans un instant votre
émission le 7-8 loisirs pour faire le
tour en des idées de sorties à faire ce
week-end dans les yvelines